growing out my favorite characters Ron
taxi junu tasks you played by
Christopher Lloyd and Latka gravis
played by Andy Kaufman back then income
comedy seems so much more observational
so which one is simpler it seems like
now everything's snarky ER and meaner in
my eye I agree with that taxi was pretty
edgy for its day and I talked to Norman
Lear about this not long ago he loved
Everybody Loves Raymond because it was
an observational show but you take
something like Modern Family it is well
the first season was great I think it's
kind of gotten stupid now it's kind of
like who cares I mean the I think the
thing you're pointing out I could be
wrong I don't mean to read your mind
after all not Orson Welles but but but
what what I think has happened is that
the network's not so much the network's
but cable of saying don't bring us
anything that isn't edgy and when you
get so edgy I don't even know what that
means
but when you go there you lose the
characters it's a great thing about taxi
was that the characters were the most
important thing the conflicts were so
human and and and you cared about all of
those people you didn't care about Lily
then Louie was a jerk and you cared
about him but they showed his vulnerable
side along yeah and I don't think that's
why Raymond was such a great show
because they did character it was all
about the characters it was all about
the conflict within the family it wasn't
they didn't try to be edgy I think they
did maybe three edgy episodes and you
know we don't even I mean again it's
like we asked all of the people in the
book what comes first character what's
the most important thing character or
story and they all said conflict and so
that's what I think that's what taxi had
but it had but you there were three
dimensional people
I mean it was broad but they were
three-dimensional well when you spoke to
Leonard Stern he said that it's much
harder to write a comedy of love and
caring than it is of negativity well I
mean again it was interesting because he
he started that by saying I agreed that
conflict is the basis of all humor but
conflict doesn't have to be hostile
and that's when he came and said I like
all of my hostility I mean all my
conflict to come out of love and you
know Geoffrey and I talked about this a
lot and when we give talks that the
standard thing there are we learned from
a lot of these writers there's there's a
bag of tricks that all comedy writers
have so when you need a laughed and
things like the turnaround joke and
things that you just here's the thing
it'll get you laugh if you're stuck and
I remember one of them saying to me the
telephone
having the telephone ring at an
inopportune time will always get you a
laugh if you have a really tense
situation in the phone rings that'll get
you laugh if you want to make it a
bigger laugh who's calling at the worst
time your mother why is that funny
because your mother has a whole bunch of
ideas of how you should be living your
life which are diametrically opposed to
yours
you'll love each other and you can't no
what do you mean you're a writer you
should have gone to pharmacy school
didn't I tell you think what you'd be
making now if you're working and you
know this it so there's a new Rite Aid
right down the street from us you could
so again it's it's that sort of thing
that it to people I Love Lucy almost
every show was people who love each
other and conflict and each one either
knows better or will show somebody
either but it was never like I'm gonna
get you I'm gonna smash your face with a
hammer
kind of
hostility it was always conflict of good
intentions and my good intentions are
better than your good intentions
you